Film Courage: Let’s suppose you attend AFM
(American Film Market) this coming year or
next and you’re sitting around with a friendly
first-time filmmaker and you say “You know,
I just want to give you 5 tips which you absolutely
must know about making your first feature
film.”
Keith Sutliff: First thing I would say, definitely
have more of a producer’s job still.
That you have the budgeting and the financing
locked in.
That you have all the money you need for the
entire film from pre-production to principle
photography, post production to distributing
and prints & advertising (P&A).
Everything.
That it’s locked in.
And then to have a set schedule and time frame
when you want to get this film out there and
not lingering and taking 5 or 10 years but
having a certain timeframe like “Hey, this
is my goal.
I want this done, complete, out to the world
by this time frame.”
There is also preparation with your cinematographer
and other people with the shot list with what
you want, your vision and talking to your
team prior and ‘This is what I think for
these certain scenes.
This is how they should look.
This is what I want.’
Collaborating with them and also I think it’s
really huge as a director have a good working
relationship with the cast and the crew (but
essentially the cast).
You are working with these people on set and
directing them, what you want them to do and
your vision.
It’s important to where you have a good
friendship and working relationship because
you’re going to spend a lot of time with
these people on set and even (some of them)
in post-production.
You’re still communicating with some of
them depending on the size of the film.
And then when it gets out to everybody, if
you’re doing a theatrical release or premiere,
everybody is going to come and support the
film.
So it’s good that you have a good working
relationship and you continue to have that.
So it’s important I think for any director.
Film Courage: That’s great.
Excellent.
Did anyone sit you down and say the same [points
to you]?
Or is this all stuff you learned?
Keith Sutliff: No.
Not really.
From experience.
This is my opinion.
Film Courage: Great tips.
Keith Sutliff: Yeah…and definitely the working
relationship.
I really want to touch base on that because
if you don’t get along with certain actors
or people as the director, it’s not going
to work.
You’re not going to work.
They are not going to respect you.
They may not put in all their effort and time
into the scenes and everything you want, so
you have to have that respect from the cast
and you have to respect them, too.
So it’s a mutual respect.
And the crew, everybody.
It’s a collaboration overall, that’s what
it is (and a business).
Film Courage: Sure.
And it doesn’t mean that they are bad actors
or bad people.
Maybe they didn’t want to really do it [the
film or take on the role] and if you do anything
with someone who is half-hearted, it creates
issues.
Keith Sutliff: Right.
You want to work with people who are passionate
and take direction well.
But also they are suggesting things “What
do you think about this?”
And you open your mind to “Yeah, we can
change that around.
That’s cool.”
You open your mind to their suggestions and
collaborating with them and having that continue
on until the film is out in the public and
continuing to work with these people over
a long time (for a career).